hello everyone this is day two of the
same fluids blitz tournament and we have
a very exciting matchup between Fabiano
Cara wanna and the Gary Kasparov Caruana
is white and Kaspar was black so let's
see it again
we have efore by Caruana c5 the sicilian
defence and Fabiano goes for Knight to
c3 he doesn't want to go he doesn't want
to allow Kasparov to play his well-nigh
Dorf
we have d69 GTV to Knight to f6 g3 g6
Bishop to g2 Knight to c6 v3 to Bishop
to g7 castles castles now a3 rook to b8
rogue to b1 b6 b4 by Khurana Bishop to
b7 now h3 nice to be 7 plus Bishop to e3
rook to e8 Queen to d2
Bishop to aah and now f4 by car wanna
rub back to c8 and now G for we have e 6
and the corona pushes at 5 we have
nicety for Bishop captures on d4 see
captors on d4 and our night to b5 we
have he captures on at 5 g captures on
f5 ignites the e5 Knight B capture some
d4 d5 Queen to f4 v captures on e4 d
captures on e4 and our Queen to c7 and
here karana plays f6 pushes this Bishop
back bishop to f8 rook to be three
nights to c4 and now Caspar offers the
exchange of Queens about the Caruana
first place I wrote the c3 we have a six
and now he captures Queen captures on c7
and rook captures on c7 and Knight to f4
will have b5 nice the d5 attacking the
rook rook seed c8r up to d3
Bishop to d6 Knights the b3 we have a
bishop captures on d5 each after sandy v
and r up to e5 like a sparrow
we have nice to see v a5 rook F to D 1 a
4 now blocking that the Queen sides
completely rocked f1 Roxy to e8
P 2 F 3 X power plays age 5 we have
Nights 2 D 3 and I'll rope the e 2 and
here Caruana tries to exchange one roof
but because pyro doesn't allow it since
he de he hid it here on the the e-file
we got rope 3 - f - a rope - - III wrote
a three rook - E -
rook 1 to F 2 and alkene - h7 and here
Corona plays Bishop - F 1 we have rook
to e4 nice to see five attacking the
rook rook to e1 and King to g2 and here
we have nice - III check and well
karana seems to have dropped upon here
but it's not it's not a catastrophe
since he was upon up so king - h1 and
the Knight captures on d5 so it's so
good it's five bondage we have work to
do
rotate the e5 Knight to d7 attacking the
rook and now rook the g5 and look at
this White King he really doesn't have a
lot of squares you can hit can go to I
mean he has no squares we have rook F 2
F 3 Bishop to c7 this Bishop has to move
since this rook was eyeing this Knight
and the bishop behind him we have a
night to C 5 H for back as part of rook
to d4 Bishop to g3 nice to D 3 and our
rook to a 1 and we have rook to e4 rook
captures on a3 because power grabs a
pawn and Carano plays rook to e7 and now
attacking this pawn but the pawn cannot
really be defended as part of that play
King to g8 but simply rook to e8 a king
- 8 7 and our rook to f8 and knock
esparto can depend upon so we have rook
day one rook captures on f7 which check
King to g8 and I'll rip the g7 check and
what part plays King to f8 and Carolina
kinda blunders the move here
he plays rook to a7 and this allows
cusps are a very nice idea and he found
it and for some time now both of them
were below 10 seconds I think it was
about 8 seconds because Parliament sinks
six seconds Caruana
or already after the man
I'm not really sure but the farmer finds
this rook there's five move and if you
look at it
okay this rook is attacked but he can't
really move because this bishop would
fall and this rook is protecting this
bishop so Corona captures Gary captures
you get Susan f5 and we have a king - G
- because well there's no way to defend
this bishop on f1 but this allows the
knight - III check and now for King the
king and the bishop we have a king tv3
and bishop can I see a person f1 we have
nice to see five rook to e1 King to g2
night - III check King to f3 Knight to
c5 and here Khurana plays rook to a six
but now well it's it's force checkmate
and Gary has a mating net we have nicety
to check King to g2 we have rook to itto
check King to h1 and rook to h2 check
and in this position Carolina resigned
because what follows is King to g1
Knight f3 check King to f1 and well a
very nice rug - f - checkmate
so yeah definitely well one of the
better games so well Kasparov played in
this tournament he did play some better
games but he didn't win them okay this
one he didn't play so good but he
managed to win and well against a
younger player with so little time on
the clock it's quite an achievement so
go Gary okay that's it for this video
not a lot of analysis since it is a
blizzard game no points to it I do hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here and I'll
see you soon